[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports pour ce deuxième numéro
de la saison on garde la recette qui a
fait la renommée de ce talk il y aura
comme d'habitude des analyses des débats
et des duels avec nos chroniqueurs ils
sont qu'à 3 autour de cette table
aujourd'hui un présentation encore un
sens à ma droite on a réussi à l'avoir
sur ce plateau juste avant les
championnats du monde sur piste master
s'il est en très grande forme physique
mais pas sûr et vous il ne va pas vous
faire un strip tease dans cette émission
ou pas on ne sait pas le capitaine yann
dujarrier piste à au club de vélizy 318
et jian comment allez-vous super vous
êtes enfin il pas le choix en pleine
bourre là maintenant on prêt à partir
donc c'est un petit peu malade non avec
une ans je me protège je me protège pour
ne rien attrapé d'ici ce week-end
prochain
on est rassuré on passe de l'autre côté
on ne le présente plus la légende le
mythe notre super chroniqueurs
spécialistes rugby coach genlis
ex-entraîneur de plaisir nous fait
l'honneur de venir dans cette émission
en pleine coupe du monde de rugby
bonjour jean boggio rigal quand allez
vous louera tous pleine forme alors moi
je comme il y en a je me protège aussi
vous protéger eux est toujours une
cravate à sion a toujours toujours une
protection
on termine de l'autre côté les rugbymans
nous vient tout droit de versailles il a
laissé à les crampons à la maison pour
venir avec un magnifique costume le
gladiateur versailles et pierre
chevalier sera avec nous pendant une
heure salut michael salut à tous quand
allez-vous pierre hébert et comme mes
camarades est en pleine forme
oui pareil on va vous êtes habillé
chaudement forme c'est l'automne en
forêt puis on fait une forme au pluriel
c'est ça alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission la ryder cup
2018 qui s'est déroulé à saint quentin
en yvelines a vu naître une idylle
sportive celle de tommy fleetwood le
britannique et francesco molinari
l'italien tous les deux ils ont remporté
leurs quatre matchs en double sur le
golf national résultats inédits lors
d'une ryder cup ce qui lui aura valu le
surnom de molly woods depuis les deux
joueurs sont inséparables regardez
[Musique]
pour thierry robert
le groupe national
[Applaudissements]
stiles
[Musique]
le
une réaction autour de cette table
j'aime beaucoup
vous avez beaucoup oui bien sûr parce
que c'est un sport qui est très très
sérieux qui peut paraître très sérieux
et justement avoir ce côté ce côté déco
dans des cadres et des collants et
décalé en dehors du en dehors du terrain
c'est voilà ça montre bien que on peut
aussi s'amuser et prendre du plaisir en
jouant golfe moi je j'adhère genre vous
adhérez vous également oui je sais trop
bien espérons qu'il fasse 3 19e trou
mais sinon oui c'est très bien ils sont
très amis en tout cas j'ai eu la chance
l'année dernière de d'être au plus près
de l'événement et 2c de ces deux
phénomènes non plus du côté sportif
woods au masters est un leader capable
d'aller gagner la ryder cup 2018 où ils
ont ils ont ils ont tout cassé en double
ils ont gagné tous leurs matches ils ont
été absolument impériaux en plus ils
avaient 7 ce côté ambiance et que les
fans européens britanniques notamment
ont transformé en slogan donc les
échelons chanson en chanson dans
l'événement de molly molly et de et de
tocs toby et plus le bollywood c'est
devenu une vraie belle histoire une
vraie belle idylle il pousse le tube de
la ryder cup on peut lire tube c'est
complètement rend complètement ça il
pousse le concept jusqu'au bout un an
après c'était en guise de clin d'oeil
c'est c'est vraiment sympa comme comme
disent mes camarades c'est vraiment
sympa de deck de dépoussiérer un petit
peu le golfe et puis de montrer que ça
peut être ça peut être sonne t ou
surprend qu'on parle encore du golf
national à un an après on n'a pas oublié
ânonner n'ont même pas oublier nous on
passe devant régulièrement enfin mais
j'aime au niveau international
finalement levé bien cher mais et puis
c'est ce grand évènement demander à un
athlète qui participent aux jeux
olympiques c'est quelque chose qui valut
à rester alité et en plus si ça se
termine bien une médaille sur un grand
événement vous l'oubliez jamais jamais
genre vous l'avez pas oublier non non
non non tu m'intéresses j'irai même plus
loin
golf national il a associé à la ryder
cup là aujourd'hui dans nos têtes
encore un an après on voit gaulle france
la ryder cup c'est c'était tellement
beau comme au championnat
et puis deux ans c'est le principe même
de la ryder cup c'est tous les deux ans
et tous les quatre ans en europe donc là
on a sept cette période de communication
intermédiaire où on est entre le entre
la coupe de la ryder cup 2018 france et
la prochaine
whissell ait aux etats-unis qui sera en
2020 donc on a sept ce petit clin d'oeil
en plus ça s'était bien passé très loin
du milwaukee un pour les adeptes de
géographie pour l'heure américaine et
donc comme dijon / pour le golf national
qui marque donc clairement identifié
comme de une ryder cup de new
c'est-à-dire un parcours qui a accueilli
la ryder cup
donc c'est bien de s'en souvenir et
c'est normal de son souvenir vue vu le
niveau de l'événement m
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler à des championnats du
monde sur piste 2022 qui sont organisés
à saint quentin en yvelines ou font
également un coup de projecteur sur
l'excellent début de saison du club de
football de versailles l'équipe a
remporté tous ses matches mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va continuer à
parler de golf
on continue donc par du golfe l'open de
france se déroulera du 17 au 20 octobre
sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituels attribué par l'european tour
l'organisateur mais cette date va
bientôt changer le tournoi va retrouver
la période estivale dès 2020 le
rendez-vous sera programmé du 2 au 5
juillet une bonne nouvelle selon le
directeur technique national christophe
muniesa
on écoute ses réactions on a travaillé
avec le tour européen pour faire en
sorte que l'open de france retrouve une
date plus clémente dans le calendrier et
on est effectivement ravis que dès 2001
l'open se déroule de nouveau fin juin
début juillet ça nous semble date plus
propice pour attirer est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec christophe muniesa la
question sur ce thème est ce que c'est
la date idéale
oui ou non oui non non pas de duel
pierre chevallier est vous êtes indécis
de vue on se place pour la pour la
partie spectacle spectateurs
oui c'est une date idéale entre début
juin et mi juillet pour le côté sportif
et côté attrait des joueurs là pour le
coup puis les spectateurs c'est
discutable parce qu'il ya évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de tournois en même
temps si on compare il faudra le refaire
je pense 5 octobre dans dans nos
prochaines éditions
entre mi octobre la semaine prochaine
pour l'open de france 2010 9 et celui de
2020 en juillet il n'y a pas photo dire
que de toute façon sur tout ce qui est
événementiel réceptif attrait des
spectateurs des nouveaux golfeurs
il faut que ce soit il vaut mieux que ce
soit en été et que le avec la météo soit
soit clémente de gaulle petite
association
ça peut être une affaire de météo si
c'est quand même c'est quand même à 95%
en extérieur je mets des 5% sur la
partie réceptive événementiel et si l'on
sait c'est que en extérieur pour suivre
les parties pour voir les joueurs donc
c'est mieux c'est mieux effectivement
quand ya pas trop de vent pas trop de
pluie pas trop de froid après c'est
moins bien peut-être sur le spectacle
pour le spectacle et le côté sportif
mais mais en tout cas retrouver une date
en entraide et et c'est plutôt une bonne
chose pour le l'open national
j'en sais très bien ce qu'elle a dit
bien sûr parce qu'on on en a parlé
déjà sur ce plateau et on a vu que cette
date au mois d'octobre
déjà première main ça attire pas
beaucoup de grands joueurs donc c'est
quand même un petit flop
ça c'est un petit peu dommage et je
pense que sur ces sur une autre date
comme elle était alors sur cette date
2020 début juillet ce sera beaucoup plus
propice à faire venir des joueurs de
d'un meilleur niveau et c'est surtout à
mon avis au niveau du spectateur
explique me plaisait pas forcément
directeur technique national christophe
muniesa il a accepté cette date mais il
n'était pas très fan des boutons
concurrence sur 7 sur cette période
beaucoup de tournois à droite et à
gauche mais à choisir entre le
la période d'octobre où seuls début
juillet y'a pas photo non plus à mon
avis parce qu'il a je pense que
christophe muniesa part du principe
qu'il vaut mieux avoir plus de
spectateurs et plus de plus d'aces
d'affluence que soient les entreprises
ou qui feront des événements à ce moment
là sur une date qui n'est peut-être
porte ivement pas idéal que le voir que
le voir que les déclassés en octobre et
en plein automne où c'est un peu moins
un peu moins agréable
ce qu'il faut dire c'est effectivement
que les sait que la concurrence sera
assez rude puisqu'il est en même temps
le world golf championship qui se joue
aux etats unis un jeune jude alassane
judée et ses succès lui qui va truster
xap 10,5 millions de dollars là on joue
pas dans la même cour
c'était le cas c'est que l'open de
france sera cette année aux alentours de
2 millions en mai 3 millions - et
c'était le cas c'était le cas quand
quand il était rolex series avec à
chennai comme comme sponsor maintenant
en termes de concurrence et l'affluence
les joueurs le top 50 mondial plus les
joueurs de riders que plus ceux de
l'asian tour vaut choisir le wgc et on
aura sûrement peut-être encore quelques
quelques joueurs qui seront pas dans le
top 50 ou d où la plupart des français
aussi qui seront avec vous sauf s'ils
sont dans top 50 ce qu'on leur souhaite
du coup ça veut dire qu'on aura la même
plateau équivalent à celui d'un grand
chelem seront autorisés pourront jouer
ne fera pas ce ne sera pas moins bien
que ce qu'on aura au mois d'octobre
cette année on aura des meilleures
conditions climatiques et en plus
certainement un meilleur plateau donc de
toutes façons ça ne pourrait être que
quelques murs pour voilà et du coup plus
de spectateurs vata sombre c'est le
cyclo cross se déroule au mois deux mois
de décembre au mois de janvier et c'est
pas pour autant que les spectateurs ne
viennent pas voir
après c'est une culture mais mais voilà
ça veut dire que quand on a l'habitude
et le plateau fait que les gens se
déplacent près qu'il faut dépasser cette
date
quel moment septe en ont parlé de
septembre il ya deux ans de plus en plus
mes mails open l'open tel sur son
sous sa configuration actuelle est
plutôt sur la sur la deuxième quinzaine
de juin plutôt fin juin et sa touche
vraiment tout début juillet en france en
fonction du calendrier la et du week-end
qui suit septembre pour être une
retraite une date pas malheur un bon
compromis entre le entre les conditions
climatiques et puis le et puis les dates
les dates concurrentes
il ya 20 septembre comme la ryder cup et
les débuts plutôt début janvier d'accord
septembre si pierlot dit on avise c'est
que c'est bon
juste après la rentrée des classes pour
faire venir les enfants au début de
saison voilà et le fait que ça ne soit
pas un relais series forcément ça la vie
la dotation plus l'attractivité au
niveau des niveaux des joueurs bien sûr
la dotation la dotation elle même et sur
le fait que certains grands joueurs
notamment du top 50 top-30 fasse des
choix en fonction en fonction des
dotations et en fonction justement des
points que ça apporte au niveau mondial
sur le circuit sur les circuits fedex
par exemple mais la question sur cette
thématique est ce que c'est ce
déplacement date peut attirer un gros
sponsor comme à chênée groupe chinois
qui avait six avant la ryder cup il ya
peut-être plus de chance sur la partie
respectives réceptive événementiel pour
les entreprises notamment avec une
possibilité de peut-être plus propice
pour justement avoir de bonnes
conditions climatiques et de pouvoir
attirer un certain un certain public
néophyte ou connaisseurs qui sera
vraisemblablement plus difficile à
attirer en obtenant en tout cas pierre
chevalier on vous retrouvera sur cet
open de france de golf serait vous y
serez quoi qu'il arrive en tout cas le
rendez vous est programmé cette année du
17 au 20 octobre
on va maintenant parler à cyclisme la
nouvelle est tombée fin à septembre le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir pour la deuxième
fois de son histoire après 2015 les
championnats du monde sur piste
le comité directeur de l'union cycliste
internationale a annoncé cette nouvelle
en grand bretagne
la compétition devrait être organisée en
octobre mais non plus à la fin de
l'hiver comme précédemment en 2015 plus
de 20000 spectateurs s'étaient rendus au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on écoute la réaction du directeur
technique national christophe manas
tell me ravit c'est toujours très
important d'avoir un championnat à la
maison donc c'est une chance pour les
équipes de france et puis c c'est une
occasion pour la fédération française de
cyclisme de démontrer c'est son savoir
faire en matière d'organisation genre
une réaction par rapport à cette
attribution
c'est très bien c'est très bien on va on
peut pas boudé gains que nous dire une
job du monde organisés dans quelques
disciplines que ce soit on a ce
vélodrome au clic un bel outil et et si
on nous donne la possibilité d'organiser
ces championnats du monde sait que 2015
a été je me souviens pas tout la beauté
des championnats du monde 2015
mais ça je suis déçu je sais j'ai eu le
faire qu'il y avait moyen des noirs
j'ai une personne et moi randonnée mais
s'écarte excès voilà je fais l'objet
carton mieux si on ne redonne les
championnats c'est qu'en 2015 ça doit
être une réussite
forcément mais c'était un tel bel outil
ce vélodrome que je me réjouis que on
accueille les championnats du monde
pierre on se réjouit justement tous deux
concerts de voir un événement cycliste
de classe mondiale venir ou revenir au
vélodrome on a souvent parlé d autres d
autres événements qui de qui te déplace
au vélodrome de 50 ans pour pouvoir lui
ne pas bouder notre plaisir quand quand
c'était un bel événement est justement
au niveau mondial pour le cyclisme sur
piste et vous qui êtes notre spécialiste
cyclisme est ce que c'est une surprise
non non je sais pas du tout ce n'est pas
une surprise puisque je vous l'avais
annoncé comme on avait les jeux en 2024
de toute façon nous aurions une édition
des championnats du monde soit en 2023
soins du 22 j'ai appris de mes 23 avec
déjà été
tribu et donc il restait que 2022 pour
pour nous donc donc c'est tant mieux
c'est très très bien qu'on puisse qu'on
puisse à nouveau organiser cette belle
épreuve qui qui va qui va à nouveau nous
nous remplir ce vélodrome très très
facilement c'était vraiment obligatoire
d'avoir des championnats du monde avant
les jeux olympiques il
les dernières éditions il ya tout ya
régulièrement alors soit une épreuves
préolympiques mais comme aujourd'hui le
calendrier de piste est plutôt à
tendance réductrice et bien voilà la
raison pour laquelle on allait avoir un
championnat diouf d'être moins en moins
de coupe du monde
voilà on essaie de réduire les coûts au
maximum donc voilà faire un championnat
du monde sur le vélodrome quelques
une de saison avant c'est quelque chose
qui va rentrer dans les moeurs de plus
en plus et qui va avec
qui va permettre à tout le monde de
faire une belle répétition deux ans
avant les jeux
la question sur ce thème est ce que
cette compétition va préparer les
français pour les jo wills est unanime
gens vous été le premier à dégainer
forcément liane l'a dit donc c'est vrai
on a les joues les pics à 2024 2022
c'est à dire une belle répétition pour
nos sportifs phrasé avant le grand
événement qui nous vient du gibier juste
avant ces championnats du monde masters
pour le père c'est par de l'eau c'est
peut-être pas de faire avec modération
et donc voilà autant que c'est une très
bonne chose pour nous et pour nos
sportifs c'est indéniable mais ce qu'on
peut comparer les géo et des
championnats du monde
le donne la parole à pierre je vous
laisse récupérer ayana réponse non mais
on a la possibilité de voir les les
jeunes et les moins jeunes se montrait
sortir du bois à deux heures à deux ans
de l'échéance sur une visibilité
mondiale donc vraiment le vraiment le le
graal et de pouvoir se tester se tester
grandeur nature à la piste elle-même à
la compétition parce qu'il faut
souhaiter aussi là il n'a y ait du monde
et que et que ça pousse derrière sur le
territoire national deux ans avant la
plus belle la plus belle échéance qui
soit sur l'olympisme donc donc c'est une
très bonne occasion pour les uns et les
autres de de se montrer et se tester à 2
ans de 2 ans de l'échéance
même si rien n'est joué des ninjas riez
vous avez récupéré ses bons parfait n'en
ont pas du tout comparé à un championnat
du monde à
à eauze olympique il ya un titre
olympique d'une la pression n'est pas la
même
le monde le monde du sport et le monde
en général à regarder je les les jeux
quel que soit quels que soient les
disciplines avec ça ça attire beaucoup
plus de visibilité
et deuxième chose le format olympique
est complètement différente du format
championnat du monde on a plus
d'épreuves sur un championnat du monde
on a moins d'épreuves sur un sur les
jeux olympiques et on a moins de
participants aussi sur les sur sur les
jeux olympiques les tournois sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus restreint il
par exemple sur sur une poursuite par
équipes il ya autant d' équipe que
qu'ils s'inscrivent à partir du moment
où ils ont marqué des points
précédemment
là les quotas ne se réduit ce cas lui
misé équipe c'est à dire que ben
directement on arrive sur des phases
finales dalle par rapport à un
championnat du monde
donc voilà c'est vraiment d
c'est des gros ses spécificités
et en effet il faut il faut pouvoir les
intégrer et s'y préparer si préparée en
amont alors on ne prépare pas sur les
championnats du monde on ne prépare pas
sur les coupes du monde c'est sait se
projeter dans la préparation 1 une
course olympique mais latente n'est pas
moins grande sur des championnats du
monde jean finalement que sur les jeux
olympiques du coup les athlètes ne sont
pas forcément dans les mêmes conditions
qu'aux jo les jo ça reste les jo c'est
sûr c'est comme l'a dit pierre tout à
l'heure c'est le championnat suprême
c'est on en parlera moins dans les
médias par exemple je changerais du
monde
il est certain qu'à part si le loup
sortie française championne du monde
hocine on ne parlera pas si la partie un
podium il y aura très peu de visibilité
ce championnat du monde malheureusement
d'ailleurs malheureusement mais alors
que les jeux olympiques c'est s'est
regardé par le monde entier donc
forcément la visibilité n'est pas du
tout le même et la préparation est la
même après bon après ouais alors après
on sportivement
moi je connais pas la réparation des 2 c
de ces sportifs mais sportivement je ne
pense pas quand même que un athlète de
haut niveau se prépare par rapport à la
visibilité que peut avoir le monde
les téléspectateurs et les spectateurs
je pense que c'est sa performance
sportive avant tout et que c'est quand
même les championnes c'est quand même
une épreuve mondiale où il va rencontrer
sanctionnant les mêmes qui rencontrera
au cours des jeux olympiques
s'il fait les 2022 2024 donc pour moi à
la préparation c'est une préparation
sportive uniquement sportive et la
concentration pour moi c'est une
excellente répétition parce que encore
une fois je répète il va il va concourir
contre quasiment les mêmes qui racontera
deux ans après donc après on a pressé
simplement plus haut au dessus mais pour
moi le côté sportif c'est une bonne
belle préparation en plus sur la piste
donc très bien pierre chevalier on peut
dire que c'est un peu la ligue 1 c'est
le
gio la ligue 2 les championnats du monde
je pensais importe ce n'est pas aussi
c'est pas aussi net que ça un titre
reste un titre gens-là l'a finement
observé ce etc
c'est un palmarès qu'on va chercher sur
des championnats du monde
certes la l'exposition médiatique n'est
pas à ce point mondiale paradoxalement
que les yeux que les jeux olympiques
mais on
je pense que la préparation est
quasiment quasiment analogue parce que
ça les sportifs sont des compétiteurs il
fondit sa ligne sur une compétition
mondiale
deux ans avant la compétition suprême
certes mais ça reste un titre donc
donc je pense que c'est faux pas
forcément dévaloriser le championnat du
monde si ce n'est peut-être sur le sur
le lenglen médiatique et la couverture
mais au niveau mental parce que ça
change ou pas il ya déjà rayé
compétition comme les jeux olympiques
par rapport à des championnats du monde
le conditionnement fléau aux
préparations peut-être non il y avait
juste un conditionnement qui est
différent comme date 1 sur 1 sur les
jeux olympiques vous êtes au village
olympique
vous êtes allés tous les autres sportifs
de toutes les disciplines présentes
comme vous êtes sur un championnat du
monde demain vous êtes entre entre
cyclistes quoi et donc du coup il s'est
passé pas la même ambiance c'est juste
une ambiance qui diffèrent
je voulais juste revenir sur un point
que pierre des pierres les deux venaient
de donner un titre de champion du monde
dans le cyclisme il a une saveur toute
particulière
vous avez su vous porter ce maillot ce
maillot arc en ciel et vous porter
pendant un an sur la discipline que vous
avez que vous ai gagné le cyclo-cross
route piste à leur vitesse poursuite etc
et vous avez la chance de pouvoir le
porter donc quand vous allez vous comme
n'importe quel moment vous allez courir
sur vos disciplines dont on va vous
reconnaitre au premier coup d'oeil parce
que vous vous allez porter ce maillot
distinctif comme le maillot jaune sur le
tour de france
est ce assez c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est très important chose que
vous n'avez pas connu de champion
olympique quand on est champion
olympique vous n'avez pas de maillot
avec avec les avec les ados des ados
n'ont donc donc voilà faut pas dénigrer
un titre de champion du monde bien bien
loin de là mais mais c'est vrai que la
résonance olympique n'est pas la même
cette dernière question sur cette
thématique est ce qu'il faudra
obligatoirement obligatoirement mettre
les athlètes de 2022 qui seront présents
aux championnats du monde en 2024 à
paris au niveau six son haut niveau
s'ils sont ses études chez pas comme ce
sont les sélections des équipes
nationales mais mais en tout cas en deux
ans il peut se passer plein de choses il
peut y avoir des éclosions comme il peut
y avoir des explosions la vérité d'une
22e ne sera pas celle de manière assez
évident même si elle n'aura pas à 100%
la même équipe
non parce que alors sur le sprint sur le
sprint on a la chance mais on a la
chance de 1024 sait danser dans six ans
je vais à thématique de broc par exemple
mais non pour moi pour moi là je me dis
un ryan et la halle un ryan et la halle
sur 2024 pourrait voir vraiment explosé
est-ce qu'il sera encore presse qui sera
déjà prêt pour 2022
je ne sais pas mais c'est vrai que là on
a une génération chez les sprinteurs
entre ryan serenella sébastien vigier
matic de gros qui va être dans ces
années où ils devraient ils devraient
vraiment trouve tout rester si les
nations les nations étrangères n'ont pas
n'ont pas sorti d'autres je dis quoi
quand je dis quoi 2020 2022 ça vous fait
sur les mots c est ce qu il faudra
sûrement m gagné sept médailles dont
cinq en or faire aussi bien que lors des
championnats du monde de 2004 par contre
en effet je pense que nos sportifs
français seront vraiment attendu sur sur
les jo de sur les championnats du monde
de 50 ans en 2022 parce que c'est à la
maison et voilà le dernier championnat
demande qui avait été dès qu'ils
s'étaient déroulés ici avait été très
très florissant pour pour les français
et ce sont les derniers où on a eu
autant de titres donc oui bien sûr que
nous atteindrons est attendue en
dominante de on passe maintenant notre
page résultats
[Musique]
on va parler à football dans cette page
résultats versailles torcy c'était l'une
des affiches de cette sixième journée du
championnat de nationale 3 après une
première période équilibrée ponctuée par
un triste 0 à 0 les versets sont plus
entreprenants au retour des vestiaires
et arrive à trouver la faille dans le
dernier quart d'heure grâce à un doublé
de benjamin louvet six fois buteur en
six matchs depuis le début de la saison
versailles et parachève sa victoire
grâce à johan aka souffle score final 3
on écoute le buteur au micro de tv
sociale vite tu veux nous de toujours
bien commencé comment s'est formé à
réussir à marquer dès le début on est
tombé contre une vraiment une bonne
équipe bien en place on a su être
patient et franchement sur la deuxième
mi temps à mettre un petit coup de folie
pour pouvoir accélérer on a eu un petit
peu de chance aussi
faut pas se mentir mais ça fait partie
du jeu aussi avec six victoires en six
matches 17 buts marqués 1 seul but
encaissé versailles réalise un début de
saison presque parfait des résultats qui
permettent aux joueurs de la cité royale
de faire cavalier seul en tête avec déjà
cinq points d'avancé sur le paris fc en
écoute le coach versailles ou pas des
prix forcément parce que je vais pouvoir
enchaîner autant de matches en étant
solide en refusant la défaite c'est que
les choses se passent entre les joueurs
est l'état d'esprit le fait d'avoir un
objectif commun
et de rester une partition sur le
terrain qui nous permet d'avoir ce
résultat la question sur ce thème sont
ils déjà champion oui ou non
cinq points d'avancé sur le deuxième
pierre chevallier
mais non mais non vous qui avez connu ça
avec versés l'année dernière voilà c'est
donc les examens une vie le sport et le
rugby ont pu voir était imprécis de
sportifs qui dit il tient à coeur bien
sûr non une saison c'est long le répète
souvent une saison c'est très très long
alors vaut mieux la démarrer par ce type
de dynamique avec six victoires et
dépendent avance ça c'est sûr ça permet
de voir venir
tout dépend à près de savoir s'il est si
les footballeurs de versailles garde
l'appétit qui est venu en mangeant et
garde justement ça tapait 10 jusqu'au
bout pour l'écraser tout sur leur
passage et marché un petit peu sur l'eau
et sur nous et sur cette poule mais les
résultats de versailles
on n'est vraiment pas à l'abri 2 0 3 0 2
0 3 0 4 1 3 0 1 seul but encaissé en six
matches c'est vrai que là les scores
sont assez éloquents pour versailles
mais met le faux pas est possible il
faut il faut guetter le relâchement et
surtout ne pas se voir trop beau ou trop
arrivé trop vite aux gens mais oui c'est
ce n'est pas très optimiste pour gérer
mais là ils sont ils sont vraiment
partie partie commandé comme des v2 donc
la cie six matches six victoires à
chaque fois il ya trois buts d'écart
quasiment sait pas chanter oui je pense
à chaque fois l'hymne de but au minimum
deux buts un seul but encaissé donc là
ils sont dans une spirale de victoires
il un magazine de la confiance mais on
n'est que six journées le problème c'est
que là maintenant versailles va être
l'équipe à battre tout le reste n 2
de la saison donc ils vont partir
archi-favori et tous les dix mecs ils
vont avoir à affronter les équipes qui
vont vouloir sortir le leur meilleur
match de la saison pour battre l'équipe
est imbattable à l'heure actuelle donc
là ce statut de favori avale avale avant
la fin du championnat
c'est quand même assez difficile à
garder à conserver pour pour leur
permettre de d'évoluer de continuer
comme ça sur leur lancée
donc ne soyons pas trop confiant un
excès de confiance peut leur jouer des
tours
il faut un excellent début de saison
qu'il continue dans cette dynamique mais
qui soit très attentif et et pour le
reste en cours
ils ne font pas forcément des matches
parfaits à chaque fois par exemple
contre torcy 0 0 à la mi temps
il gagne 3-0 finalement est-ce que
certains matches peuvent basculer en
leur faveur en ce début de championnat
mais peuvent basculer dans l'autre sens
juste après c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre un de champion et
deuxièmement c'est doux c'est justement
le petit côté chance qui qui fait que
les masses basques des matchs parce que
nouveau trois heures mais il appelle 3
000 à la saison que je veux dire 0-0 à
la mi-temps et 3 0 au final un match qui
bascule en sa faveur c'est quand il ya
un à un à la 85e et puis on marque de 1
à la 89e
voilà ça c'est un match qui bascule
enfin saveur quand vous en mettez trois
sur la deuxième mi temps
voilà la première à prendre vu les buts
un petit peu chanceux la première
mi-temps sanguin une nomination que le
collectif est en place qu'à une
domination
les buts sont peut être chanceux mais
ils sont quand même ils attaquent ils
attaquent le cas inverse il y domine
donc on ne peut pas c'est pas c'est pas
si c'est sauve qui peut la suivre
notamment sur le choix de 3e le
troisième but c'est effectivement un
sujet pas je suis là
celui là il ne reviendrait pas mais ils
sont trop tôt du ballon au grand
défenseur et yéro boly fixation dessus
du gardien les chances mais le facteur
chance est important ça c'est sûr et ça
fait partie de des paramètres d'une
saison de champion vraiment quand
certains matchs un petit peu un petit
peu haché que ça bascule en aux saveurs
mais je suis d'accord avec eux yann
basculer en leur faveur en collant 3 0
c'est plutôt confort et et ça ne fait
pas que six matches qui ne perdent pas
en tout cas qu'ils gagnent ça fait vingt
matches
une vingtaine de matchs d'affilée qui
n'ont pas perdu depuis la saison dans
les buts la saison dernière mais la
baisse par rapport aux six matches c'est
quand même un quart du championnat
vu que c'est des championnats et 14 14
14 équipes ça veut dire 13 matches aller
13 matches retour quand on en a fait 6
ans a déjà fait un tiers du championnat
donc je trouve que voilà ils ont quand
même mis ainsi pour vous êtes les
matsuda leur journée 4 x 6 led caf se
voit quelle bêtise ils réfléchissent 14
aussi vous regardez
[Musique]
retrouvons les esprits vous qu'être
coach comment on doit gérer du coup la
suite du championnat
ab pour moi je dédie cette vidéo algérie
comment ils ont le statut de favori ils
ont le statut de l'équipe à battre lyon
en fait un petit peu les les têtes c'est
à lui c'est à lui justement oui à ce que
son groupe reste après on les sent pas
forcément ils ont les 100 concentré
quand même dans les interviews produits
dont le tout à fait non mais là il donne
même lucidité et une belle humilité et
là ils se prennent pas pour des propos
pour des stars moment ils sont pour moi
pour moi le groupe est bien en place
ensuite vous dit 0 0 à la mi temps 3 0
l'a fait un match un match de foot c'est
90 minutes
donc c'est à la fin du bal qu'on paie l
orchestre donc et c'est le résultat
final qui compte de 3-0 il n'y a pas
photo il ya sûrement du répondant du
répondant à apporter dans la suite de la
saison donc c'est là qu'il faut pas
qu'ils se relâcher quiconque qui
continue à marcher sur l'île est certain
que c'est plus facile de l'alsace là
comme thalasso dynamique de victoires
que le contraire mais ça pourrait plus
dur va être de marquer le premier but
dans chaque sur chaque match est une
fois qu'ils auront mis deux premiers
buts l'adversaire va prendre un gros
coup au moral est derrière ce sera déjà
match gagné quasiment à chaque fois
dernière question sur cette thématique
versailles va affronter courcouronnes en
coupe de france ce dimanche 13 octobre
une victoire et une qualification pour
le 6e tour permettrait de bonifier
encore un petit peu plus ce début de
championnat est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
est ce qu'il faut faire un beau parcours
en coupe de france pour valider ce bon
début de championnat
il ya du jarrier évidemment évidemment
la coupe de france pour ne pas laisser
de côté en un an mais pas du doigt la
filière premier toute façon c'est
économiser notre énergie
c'est une émulation positive ça voilà on
est toujours cette spirale
et si en plus de faire un beau
championnat il arrive à aller pouvoir
aller perdre contre une contre une belle
équipe de pros bah c'est tout ce qu'on
peut c'est tout ce qu'on peut leur
souhaiter quoi l'année dernière il avait
perdu au 8e tour contre lens un type de
ligue 2 avril de nombreux maux boron 4 à
et ils menaient 2 1 pierre chevalier
vous êtes d'accord oui je suis d'accord
il faut donc à faire là ils ont isolé
a priori un bon groupe un bon état
d'esprit le facteur chance qu'il faut un
entraîneur qui est qui est bien
concentré et ça dure déjà depuis depuis
la saison dernière avec ces labels zafy
belle affiche que que vous citez donc
tant qu'à faire court on plusieurs
lèvres lièvres à la fois et ça pourra ça
pourra justement donné de belles
surprises
après j'y apporterai juste un tout petit
bémol jean je ne connais pas l'effectif
dont il dispose il faut faire quand même
attention aux blessés et à multiplier
les journées de championnat et un maître
en bus de la coupe
attention quand même qu'ils ne fassent
pas trop de sauver ce sixième tour les
manières ils sont fait sortir au 8e tour
en contrôle milk deuxième tour si galati
cydia et les voilà six ans plus de liste
de blessés donc attention à peinture
jouer stratégique ibis la prudence on
souhaite bon courage en tout cas à
verser pour la suite du championnat on
passe à notre page débats
on continue à parler de football et plus
précisément de vince qui selon le vous
dit peut-être rien mais c'est un youtube
heures ultra connu dans le monde du
ballon rond
il est originaire de buchelay dans les
yvelines ce sportif a notamment fait des
vidéos avec florian thauvin cristiano
ronaldo encore sergio ramos rien que ça
il a également fait des vidéos en
réalisant des défis mais depuis la
rentrée vince qui s'élance et justement
un nouveau défi celui de créer une
équipe de football dans sa ville
baptisée vince qui fc il a fait une
vidéo pour expliquer ce choix dans les
yvelines dans 78 en région parisienne du
coup alors pourquoi tu as demandé
pourquoi ce sont 18 parce que moi là bas
je suis un mec qui vient de boucler à
verser quoi bûcher voilà c'est pas connu
c'est un petit village
j'aime pas combien on est à buchelay
3100 fin de cet habitant en 2016
c'est là où j'ai grandi voilà celle où
j'étais en école primaire je suis allé
dans une villa côté s'appelle
magnanville au collège et au lycée mont
région parisienne tous les terrains sont
utilisées par des clubs des associations
etc
c'est très compliqué de trouver un
créneau très très très compliqué j'ai
contacté monsieur martinez qui est le
maire de buchelay j'ai proposé le projet
il a adoré il a qui fait le projet il a
envie de soutenir à fond notre
initiative donc là quand j'ai vu ça je
me servais ont redonné du baume au coeur
parce que ça fait des semaines que
j'essaie de trouver un terrain que
j'avais des réponses négatives mais le
problème c'est que la bûche n ya pas de
terrain de foot donc là j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu décomposé comme a dit
ça je suis dit mais en fait ils
assureront qui auront pas ce que je veux
dire m'a dit t'as qu'à pas venir cacher
un projet sur le long terme où j'ai
envie de créer un terrain de foot à
buchelay ça nous en parlerait dans une
autre vidéo je vous montrerai
concrètement les terrains ce que mon là
je suis dans mon studio
mais en attendant on va trouver des
villes qui peuvent vous accueillir en
attendant vous évolueront donc à mantes
la jolie qui est une ville juste à côté
de buchelay bras c'est vraiment une vie
pour le coup ci a beaucoup plus
d'habitants dont un complexe sportif
s'appelle la bu deux verres on aura un
créneau hebdomadaires d'entraînement le
dimanche les matches mais des fois à
domicile ça sera du coup à mantes la
jolie et à l'extérieur ce sera dans la
ville bacon affrontera le fc wiltz qui
espère faire monter le club en ligue 1
vince qui en tout cas elle se fait
remonter le club en ligue 1 le fc vince
qui dans 13 ans très exactement ce n'est
pas forcément gagné pour son premier
match de son histoire le fc vince qui
s'est incliné 4 à 2 sur la pelouse dieu
menthe olympiques du monde olympique
alors une petite réaction
treize ans en ligue 1 c'est possible
c'est très ambitieux c'est très
ambitieux ça donne un éclairage
particulier à ces youtuber qui sont
décrits sous qui ont inventé des
nouveaux métiers et qui désormais ont
des nouveaux moyens
ce que je trouve sympa c'est que c'est
qu'il n'oublie pas d'où il vient
malgré le succès en quoi qu'on puisse en
penser
sur le moyen youtube mais il n'oublie
pas d'où il vient et il ay l'a77 fibre
du football et cette envie justement de
rendre ce qu'il a connu à buchelay dans
les yvelines
ça me fait d'ailleurs penser qu' il ay
là avec eux petit pont qui est le
journal des des petits fans de footeux
de foot
il a réalisé le record du monde du petit
pont et donc on a vu cette année c'est
avec un voile avec un avec plein peu
plein d'enfants sûrement du coin et de
et d'île de france et donc voilà il fait
ça c'est avec avec ce magazine pour les
pour les jeunes amateurs de football
voilà il utilise son aura il utilise son
sa visibilité pour pouvoir après lancé
lancé un certain nombre de projets et
celui là on est en est un
particulièrement ambitieux mais vous lui
souhaite
on lui souhaite tout le succès tout le
succès que peut-être que bûche les
mérites pour le football jean vous êtes
convaincu la ligue 1 de 13 ans la ligue
entre pourquoi pas non sportivement
gamin c'est c'est bon c'est un petit peu
présomptueux on va dire sportivement ce
serait quand même dénigrer dénigrer le
côté sportif c'est très difficile puis
on a plus on monte dans le niveau qu il
est difficile de monter au niveau
supérieur
et ça dans toutes les disciplines donc
là c'est quand même des pailles plutôt
dit je veux rencontrer une ligue 1 dans
treize ans de france
mais il est en d6 exactement d66
commence forcément c'est à dire des
mille îles
l'objectif du club cette année c'est le
même dieng moi un mandat qui sont toutes
en belgique du club ils ont raison perdu
leur premier match on l'a vu a justement
pour leurs objets mais les vidéos en
tout cas cartonne sur internet ils font
plus de 300000 vu l'équipe est
sponsorisé par un grand équipementier
sportif et par un site de pari en ligne
on voit que ça attire les sponsors et le
club pourrait avoir les moyens de ses
ambitions et donc la ligue 1 durant 13
ans et bouliac bossi melreux sauf que
les moyennes c'est une chose mais il ya
quand même le coach comme jeudi les
moyens il peut les avoir par rapport à
son succès par rapport à ces vidéos mais
les moyennes c'est une chose le côté
sportif en est une autre
c'était si facile de si c'était qu'une
question de moyens pour être un beagle
il y aurait beaucoup plus de club qui
est qu il ne saurait donc mais je pense
que aujourd'hui en effet paris galère
pour gagner la champion's league mais
accéder à la ligue 1 si on a les moyens
je pense que c'est pas quelque chose qui
est qui
utopique et aussi je pense pas qu'il
faut faire quelque chose de collectif
jarrier on apprend à compter après bon
et bien voilà les jeux moi j'aime bien
ce cet effet de rêve est de se dire on
va essayer et motivés en tout cas mais
voilà et derrière de son aura il a déjà
des partenaires combien de clubs
régionaux galère pour pouvoir boucler
les budgets
ça va pas être le cas de cette commune
d'accord ils vont avoir quand on l'a
budget marine et cantona budget on peut
aller prendre des joueurs à droite à
gauche
et si on n'a plus d'argent que les
jouets les autres clubs alentour on peut
ramener et bien sûr qu'après le forfait
intrants débuts au début s'il a une
grosse équipe avec des joueurs qui sont
largement au dessus du niveau ça va
monter très vite
sauf qui va arriver très vite à
nationale par exemple comme versailles
de la nationale 3 mais même là mais
voilà il y sera loin encore de la dengue
est gamin voilà il sera encore loin de
l'adn et déjà quand tu arrives à l'aise
à niveau comme la nationale 3 il te faut
pas que les moyens il faut le côté
sportif
donc au delà au delà des moyens
justement il va avoir un problème assez
vite c'est le problème des
infrastructures et de sa ville et donc
le choix justement la municipalité ou de
la ville qui va qui va choisir qui va le
choisir où il va choisir parce que si on
fait l'état des lieux des plus petites
équipes en ligue 2 ou en ligue 1 c'est
quand même des c'est quand même des
villes de province qui sont qui sont qui
sont d'une certaine taille ou d'une
taille certaine guingamp s'avère dijon
amiens qui sont donc qui navigue entre
la ligue 2 et là est le cas en ce moment
c'est quand même c'est quand même des
villes du bonne taille et une bonne
structure
là je suis pas sûr que buchelay et les
reins pour pouvoir justement accompagner
ce projet 6 mars et qui régna la rue ben
il va y avoir beaucoup de gens qui vont
suivre l'aventuré si les premières
années se déroule bien
ça peut vraiment faire effet boule de
neige c'est ça peut être vraiment une
belle aventure et il ya aura justement
pour pouvoir accéder à cette équipe en
sélection
donc il peut y avoir une histoire
c'était l'objectif est également leurs
points
la question sur cette thématique
est-ce que ça permet de parler un autre
public finalement de passer par youtube
quand on voit qui médiatise son équipe
sur une saison on peut peut-être savoir
un peu connaître un petit peu les
difficultés les côtés positifs d'un club
de foot genre parce que ça permet de
communiquer avec les jeunes tout
simplement dans le but d'attirer plus de
monde dans le football ça c'est sûr là
haut niveau au niveau jeunes ça sert
thèmes plus sauf que le football et
youtube on va dire moi ont des
dénominateurs communs dire qu'on arrive
je pense à parler assez facilement dans
un sens et dans un autre de football sur
youtube de youtube sur feu dans le
football et ça permettra de justement de
d'installer sept
cette notoriété du football comme comme
sport populaire numéro 1 notamment en
france
en revanche ça peut ça peut intéresser
certains qui s'était qui s'était
fourvoyé vers le ver le gaming et le 10
sport et devenir vraiment chausser les
crampons et d'aller courir sur un
terrain de foot pourquoi pas vous est
lui plutôt optimiste plutôt optimiste
oui je trouve l'initiative l'initiative
intéressante on lui souhaite plein de
succès elle sera semé d'embûches et on
lui souhaite plein de succès en sur art
etc attention en tout cas le fc à vince
qui en tentera d'avoir vince qui en
plateau dans une émission ce n'est pas
gagné mais on va essayer on va continuer
cette émission en parlant une nouvelle
fois du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines fin septembre
l'équipe de france de bmx freestyle full
flat s'est rendu dans la structure pour
une démonstration objectif présenter
leur discipline à quelques jours des
premiers championnats du monde en
novembre prochain en chine on écoute
justement l'un des membres de cette
équipe de france le très médiatique
matthias dandois star également des
réseaux sociaux au micro de tv 78 gens
pensent que j'avais jamais vu c'est
hyper impressionnant c'est vachement
plus pentue que ce que je pensais et
mais qu'ils ont déplu encore plus grosse
que ce que je pensais
ils ont des grosses cuisses c'est grand
c'est cool je crois qu'on a une
initiation à la piste demain
il me tarde grave moi je fais du vélo
tout le temps à paris et du coup là ça
va être un peu différent mais j'ai une
toute petite cuisse - je pense que ça a
marché
yann est ce que vous avez des grosses
cuisses ou non parce que je suis le
sprint car je suis le sprinteur qui
ressemble à un poursuiteur mai
on n'est pas oubliée et d'avoir des
grosses mises je vais prendre l'exemple
de theo bos qui est à plus haut niveau
et qui est champion du monde qui a été
champion du monde et chez les élites qui
n'a pas des grosses cuisses là on n'est
pas c'est pas une obligation mais je
l'appelais les sprinteurs qu'il a pu
voir au vélodrome nous nos sportifs à
nous en effet sébastien grégory baugé
s'est passé c'est qu'il a vu rouler en
effet eux ils ont ensemble la légende a
été un peu surpris tous les postures
alors le bmx freestyle flat est une
discipline de plus en plus plébiscité
pour intégrer allez jo des rumeurs sur
une participation de cette discipline à
paris en 2024
enfin on écoute matthias dandois les jo
c'est possible il ya des ça parle pas
mal dans le dans les backstage et après
c'est pas à moi de prendre cette
décision mais si on me demande d'y aller
et j'arrive à me qualifier gérer avec
plaisir pour représenter la france même
trajet ce père serait cool
la question sur ce thème le bmx
freestyle mérite il sa place aux jo on
parle de flat un oui ou non
oui non jean pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
êtes pourquoi il ya déjà il ya déjà le
bmx
normal quoi dans une discipline on sait
bien ce à cause de bmx rajouter c'est
s'est rajouté finalement non pas une
discipline une épreuve à une discipline
qui existe déjà
alors je pense qu'il ya d'autres
disciplines qui pourrait prendre la
place plutôt que rajouter une épreuve
dans une discipline qui existent déjà
aux jeux olympiques ou pour ce tout
après il ya plusieurs disciplines où
c'est le cas
queens on met lass et techniques chômage
technique
je vais déjà en 2020 justement à tokyo
il y aura le bmx parc qui sera intégré
vous rendez compte le principe c'est que
ça se déroule dans skate park
oui non mais là alors là c'est le plus
puissant
c'est de plus en plus techniques
j'ai peur quand même qu'on s'écarte un
petit peu de la fonction première de djo
quoi c'est dans la mouvance de ses
nombreux sports de rue urbain qui qui
pose la question en se développant de
savoir s'ils doivent être reconnu comme
un sport comme une discipline et s'ils
doivent être reconnu à l'échelon suprême
pour être pour devenir olympique
je suis pas sûr que toutes ces disputes
malgré le malgré l'intérêt populaire que
ça peut avoir et la progression
justement dans l'eure dans la popularité
méritent tous leur place aux jeux
olympiques
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas suffisamment de
place pour être un sport olympique
là en l'occurrence dans cette discipline
là il ya sous il ya déjà le bmx le bmx
la cobac les courses classiques boss et
lycées en ligne et en ligne et qu'il a
très spectaculaire qui peut je pense
largement satisfaire tous les amateurs
de bmx
après maintenant proposer des figures en
flat audio je suis pas sûr que c'est
vraiment ce dont ce sport est besoin ou
c'est à discipliner besoin c'est comme
quand on parlait du hip hop ou je ne
sais plus qui je pense qu'on est un peu
moins voir très loin des valeurs
qu'imaginer couverte en en créant
l'olympisme
il ya le skate notamment le surf
l'escaladé le breakdance qui intégreront
les jo de 2024 on est vraiment une
culture urbaine c'est ce que disait
pierre cheval sauf le surf mais c'est
pour le seigneur je suis je suis je suis
pleinement enfin bref je crois tu mens
contre même si c'est une discipline du
cyclisme et alors les raisons pour
lesquelles je suis content c'est que si
ce type de discipline entre il va
falloir enlever une discipline au
cyclisme et donc ça va être encore la
piste qui va qui va morfler selon damien
demeure se ferait le vtt qui sauteraient
et voilà alors donc pour faire sauter le
vtt le vtt est considéré comme le sport
qui coûte le plus d'argent en termes
d'infrastructures plus qu'un stade et
les français selon un rapport que les
français les français marchent très bien
embêté
y'a pas de raison de faire sauter le vtt
oui mais alors après oui mais le gros
problème qui y assure c'est sur ces
disciplines pour moi c'est le côté des
disciplines artistiques
en général c'est que ben pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir d'aider donner un vainqueur
il faut que ce soit c'est un jury qui
s'en occupe et donc du coup on peut
avoir les mêmes dérives que l'on a avec
la boxe ou bains et voilà et donc on a
après le le canton n'est pas spécialiste
mais on a du mal à apprécier la vraie
valeur entre différents différents
adversaires et la voilà quand les juges
donnent leurs notes qui sont souvent
noté avec des dixièmes de points c'est
vrai que c'est toujours difficile à
apprécier
et donc voilà des titres qui va être non
sans chanvre et sans vraie valeur et
puis alors après la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'il ya aucun intérêt
d'intégrer aux jo c'est qu'ils ont déjà
des x games tous et tous et tous ces
sports tous ces sports de rue donc ils
ont leur place ils ont leur l'heure mais
c'est dans l'air du temps finalement
quand on regarde matthias dandois par
exemple qui à 2 123 mille abonnés sur
les réseaux sociaux alors que la
fédération française de cyclisme compte
31 mille abonnés est ce que finalement
est ce que finalement il faudrait pas
intégré à un matthias dandois dans
programmant la marque il faut que la
fédération française de cyclisme change
sont la grosse différence elle est là
parce que en effet ça apporte du publi
la boîte oui mais la boîte de com qui
s'occupe d'eux qui fait pas son boulot
auprès de la fédé
et voilà c'est la raison c'est le
résultat est là c'est comme n'y a pas
d'information comme il n'ya rien n'y a
rien qui en découlent rien à suivre et
et je vais prendre l'exemple des jeux
pas de bras pas dégeu pardon des
championnats d'europe d'athlétisme qui
auront lieu l'année prochaine à charléty
monfils fait d'appeler voilà en france
mon fils fait déjà de l'athlé fait de
l'athlétisme et donc j'ai reçu une
invitation pour prendre des places pour
des cours de l'année prochaine au mois
d'août quand la fédération française de
cyclisme organise un événement en france
eh bien on n'a jamais l'information donc
si on n'est pas spécialisée si on va pas
chercher l'info il ya un problème
donc voila et la fédération française de
cyclisme a d'énormes progrès à faire sur
son sur sa com fait de devenir olympique
va se passer le ballon
l'audience à un million de youtube en
jeu jean-loup de la fin pour 200 m il
s'élèvera à séville et le zoo a dit que
c'est sur le bon on passe maintenant
notre page découverte
dans cette page découverte une sirène
dans les eaux heavy noise et oui vous
avez bien entendu la plaisir oise julie
peugeot 30 ans baigne dans le maire
meeting depuis un an une discipline un
solide qui allie natation et beauté avec
un costume de femme poisson en
élasthanne cette discipline requiert une
préparation physique la sportive plonge
deux fois par semaine en piscine on les
gouttes
le maire meding est un sport on nous
demande des performances en apnée en
général je suis sur 40 secondes une
minute quinze mois encore vous avez
des figures à faire si vous souhaitez en
effet elles sont pas imposés mais en
effet il ya des vernis on doit aussi
également savoir poser sous l'eau on va
dire en mode très statique en complément
julie s'entraîne trois fois par semaine
sur terre dans une salle de sport
sécession lui ont permis de se présenter
au concours miss france de la discipline
épreuve qu'elle a remporté en juillet
dernier en bretagne face à huit
candidates
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'y étais allé en plus tôt en
mode plutôt défi personnel
je voulais vivre aussi une expérience
avec d'autres sirènes parce que c'est
pas tous les jours que l'on peut
rencontrer des sirènes en france donc
cet événement nous a permis de nous
regrouper de nous partager nos valeurs
nos connaissances nos savoir faire
julie espère désormais participer à un
concours interne semaine de sirène
programmes en egypte début 2020 avec un
appui est revenue une nouvelle fois de
l'écharpé à la maison la question sur ce
thème que pensez vous de cette
discipline
on valide ou pas je vois très motivés
oui c'est on n'a pas vu grand chose
notons en tant qu'auteur l'a pas vu
quelque chose à ses collègues je le
connaissais pas c'était très court ça a
l'air brossât voilà la vue ça a l'air
sympathique cérémonie trouve dommage
qu'il ne soit pas là aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai fait je vais pas dire que ça se
rapproche de la pole dance mais c'est
vrai que là on parle de sport artistique
et de sport au mans jacques est liée à
la pluie les anciens tous drapés lettre
le président rappelle aux testeurs et
c'est vrai que je quand je vois
certaines de figure que la demoiselle
fait et comme je suis comme je suis et
l'aide sur sur facebook je vois je vois
certaines similitudes et dommages de
masse qu'elle soit pas là pour en parler
le reportage a fait ces gracieux et ses
graphiques
donc je ne connaissais pas du tout cette
discipline je ne savais pas qu'il y
avait un concours de miss france irène
sait très bien qu'on est con et une
locale régionale de l'étape formidable
je plais jeunesse qui s'entraînent à la
piscine salvador allende des
clayes-sous-bois si vous voulez vous
renseigner d'accord et je pense que ça
allie un certain nombre j'aurais
sûrement on a moins de grâce que cette
jeune fille je pense que ça allie un
certain nombre de disciplines et de
d'efforts à faire en termes artistiques
en terme sportif
l'apnée en plus chapeau après une 15 je
trouve pas que c'est ces quelques en
faisant des figures ouais enfin mon avis
si vous avez des pics et un ami à moi
qui fais de la bibli noir halak et
dernier film a aussi qui fait de l'apnée
il fait pas de figure mais il reste
plusieurs minutes je crois que c'est
autour de 6,7 un truc comme ça donc on
en est quand même très très loin et je
pense qu'il ya peut-être un peu plus de
travail à faire sur qui lui permettrait
de pouvoir de pouvoir faire de faire
mieux et de faire de faire plus il est
vrai à saly apnée et également botté
leurs figures qu'après qu'elle le phoque
est chassé qu'elles fassent à sa photo
qu'un second d'où qu'elle la fasse en
une quinzaine à banias pas l'intérêt
mais mais voilà je trouve qu'il ya des
choses sympas affaires et mais après en
terme de d'exploits sportifs la minute
15 ça me laisse pas
par ailleurs sinon c'est linge une
piscine ou dans un bocal
c'est un accord entre son rêve c'est
d'intégrer un aquarium pour les jeudis
vrai jeu parce que il y à des
professionnels des sirènes
professionnels et notamment l'aquarium
de paris et elle voudrait faire la même
chose dans un autre aquarium de france
voilà pour donner s'il est d'accord
c'est un beau métier
est ce que la rumeur par laquelle il ya
il va y avoir en bretagne une miss a
fait une élection de miss france ton
concurrence avec jeune candidat mr
vending que des candidats n'en a pas
entendu parler en peut-être une fausse
info en tout cas la queue de sirène
c'est une monopalme ans je tiens à
préciser
ah oui je sais que vous posiez la
question est aujourd hui je vous devais
emmener jeter un tag spécialistes par
contre il ya mr triton je crois oui mais
ce n'est pas une blague
pour le coup mr triton mais ces deux
c'est de mieux en mieux mais c'est de
plus en plus de cela vous inspire
on se calme a dit en avoir trois ans
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui focus sur une
citation du nageur américain michael
phelps les limites n'existent pas plus
vous rêverez plus vous irez loin je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]